ÇIch begleitete ein Projekt in SŸdkamerun, ...
... ein Forst-Landwirtschaftsprojekt.
So kamen wir auf die Idee, einen Film zu drehen ...
...fŸr die Sendung "mitenand".
DafŸr wollten wir in SŸdkamerun...
... Kakaobauern filmen.È
ÇWir fanden dort eine Familie, welche eine Tochter hatte,
die in der Hauptstadt Germanistik studierte .
Weil diese Leute wussten, dass Schweizer kommen, ...
... holten sie ihre Tochter.È
ÇIch sagte: Guten Morgen!
Und er: Bonjour!È
Ich dachte: Was ist das denn
fŸr ein Komischer!È
Wir haben den ganzen Tag zusammen verbracht.
Viel geredet und diskutiert.È
ÇWŠhrend Monaten kommunizierten
wir per Messenger.
Dann ging ich wieder dorthin wegen meines Projekts
und konnte sie wieder besuchen.
Wir redeten dann schon darŸber,
ob sie mich vielleicht mal besucht.
Dadurch, dass ich den Botschafter gut kannte, ...
... bekamen wir ein Visum, ...
... so dass sie mich fŸr drei Monate besuchen konnte.
In diesen drei Monaten lernten wir uns dann
etwas kennen und fŠllten bereits eine Entscheidung.
Bereits ihr nŠchster Aufenthalt musste dann schon so sein,
dass sie in die Schweiz kommt und wir heiraten.È
Unsere Hochzeit! Ich denke immer:
Wir sollten diese Zeremonie nochmal machen!
Ich war so neu hier, ...
... alles war neu fŸr mich!
Ich konnte es nicht geniessen!
Alles war neu!
Alles musste schnell gehen!
Die zivile Hochzeit und die kirchliche Hochzeit,
alles musste man schnell machen.
Ich mšchte gern nochmal!È
ÇInteressant war die Reaktion
meiner Mutter, als ich zurŸck kam, ...
... und ich ihr sagte, dass ich mich verliebt habe.
Sie wusste ja, dass ich ein Hilfsprojekt habe
und vom Typ her allen helfen will.
Also sagte sie zu mir: Du tust das nicht,
weil du ihr helfen willst, oder?!
Ich fand das eine gute Frage.
Und ich konnte ihr sagen: Nein!
Weil ich sie wirklich liebe.È
ÇOje!
Hm... Ich bin auch ein bisschen pingelig.
Ich wŸrde nicht sagen ...
Oje Patrick...!
Ich weiss nicht. Das ist schwierig.
Kannst du mir etwas sagen?È
ÇManchmal Ordnung machen, nicht?È
ÇNein - das ist nicht typisch schweizerisch.È
ÇJa, er macht immer Fondue!È